the problems plaguing the biden
administration they are only getting
worse and the white house does not seem
to have an answer to the key issues that
has many americans fed up gas prices
topping four dollars a gallon in all 50
states for the first time and a new
prediction says it will surge past six
bucks this summer and stocks getting
rocked this week with new warnings at
america could be headed for a deep
recession and parents were still very
frustrated that the president waited
until yesterday evening to directly deal
with the baby formula shortage the end
result to all this only 25 percent of
americans think the country is headed in
the right direction top recovering kevin
mccarthy says it has to do with a lack
of leadership
everything this president has touched he
has failed that but he has made america
weaker in that process and we've watched
the democrats inside congress and senate
mirror those same decisions but the bad
headlines and disgruntled voters are not
stopping some in the media from making
this claim watch if you embrace the
biden agenda it's going to get you far
you know there's a lot to run on here
the economy is doing well i realize
inflation is an issue the byte
administration is trying to address but
we have record job growth under this
administration
we have
jobs that people actually want to be
working in that are high wage and income
earning jobs
there's a lot to be proud of and there's
a lot to talk about
jesse that's some spin chuck todd didn't
even buy that spin he did it he buys a
lot of spin remember in the 70s or the
80s the gong show dana one of the best
shows so you walk out on stage and you
do your little song and dance and then
eventually the audience has had enough
and they come over and they take the
little
and they just bang that gong and he's
off or she's off this summer they're
gonna hit the gong on biden you're gonna
have not only gas at six you're gonna
have electricity prices through the roof
and everyone's going to be cranking the
ac because it's going to be so hot and
they're talking brownouts and blackouts
so you add that to crime which is going
to come up in the summer it gets hot
people stay out late in chicago tonight
they start shooting that's gonna happen
then you just sprinkle in another coved
wave oh we're back to covet waves people
want to put their masks back on that's
going to be another really irritating
situation and then there's no baby
formula we have a lot of people that are
very uncomfortable with the waves of
immigrants coming across the border
unchecked title 42 is out in a day or so
so that's going to be on the tv screen
you're going to have people feeling a
lot of pain a lot of misery and people
are going to be hurting and i don't see
how biden at this stage of his
presidency is able to deal with that
because he doesn't have any answers
rhetorically policy-wise he's tried to
lower gas prices he hasn't done that
he's done nothing on inflation the fed
blew it so what's his plan he doesn't
have a plan and he doesn't have the
rhetorical skill set or the energy to
get himself out of this hole and the
democrats are going to say man you're
going into a midterm with things this
badly they're just going to start
jumping ship
jessica
the baby formula crisis to me is sort of
it pulls all of it together in one
issue that you could see um the i would
say incompetence late to the game trying
to blame other people and finally
getting to a result that's way too late
but here's mika brzezinski she was
talking to the surgeon general about
this issue and get your response
did the white house and did the
government take too long to act
well mika the fda began acting as soon
as they knew that the plant was going to
shut down and so they were already
taking action several months ago and we
they've continued to ramp up the actions
i'm not feeling in intensity when are we
going to see formula in the mouths of
babies in america without any stress in
terms of getting it let me assure you
that every conversation i've had with
people at the fda in the white house
has reflected the intensity you're
talking about because again this is not
just a policy issue this is personal uh
for many people
jessica you uh are a mom
before last time i saw you you were
looking for formula right yeah i've been
looking for formula since cleo was two
months old that's when the recall
happened the abbott recall that then
everyone uh went to the products that
were still on the shelves or were safe
and the mayhem in these moms groups
about checking the numbers on the
formula
batch numbers on your box uh
started back in february so i was
surprised and we were talking about this
last week i was out of the country that
this should have been a story months ago
i don't know actually how it wasn't
because certainly everyone that i knew
with a small baby was aware of it even
if you were breastfeeding your baby you
knew i think it's because the media is
obsessed with the former president and
they just didn't cover it
i think and
i don't want to play the gender card on
this but this falls on moms most of the
time i mean my husband who's
you know wildly productive as a dad and
takes care of cleo all the time
doesn't think about her formula 24 hours
a day i know how many cans are in the
cabinet i know who i've asked i have 10
people on the lookout i have a friend
who's like i'm going to seattle check
the shelves there
and
i was certainly upset that it wasn't
being talked about more but then you got
to wonder so like the last two weeks
it's been all about you know biden was
late to the game and they were late to
the game and abbott is certainly to
blame for this
but why did 192 republicans vote against
the formula bill yesterday oh there's
good reasons actually well yeah there
aren't lots of reasons
no actually when you look at you would
have voted against that bill yeah or
against the one to let women use uh
their supplemental nutrition benefits no
i think that one was fine but adding 28
million dollars to a thing that they
didn't even need the money for and
fda already got a 102 million dollar
increase this year this wasn't about
money was it the fact that nobody did
anything about the question is where is
the money going if they knew this was
happening in february they got 100
million dollars and they still can't
solve the problem and generally broadly
speaking all of these problems you know
joe biden ran as an everyday guy good
old joe who was in touch with the
working class blue collar workers the
average american he's actually turned
out to be a liberal uh limousine liberal
that is back because whether it's
inflation and the the chief of staff
saying it's a high class problem whether
it's joe biden last friday saying oh
i'll answer questions from the media
about the formula crisis because
not because moms are worried but because
it's on the front of every newspaper in
america and then you have the surgeon
general saying well the conversations
that i'm having americans want results
they want things to be moving and then
also you had the pentagon spokesperson
today john kirby being asked by charles
payne in the four o'clock hour so when
can americans expect this this operation
of flying formula in from overseas to
actually happen when is this going to be
something on the shelves and he says i
don't have a timeline for you right and
the reason they're saying that is
because they don't want to put out a
timeline that they are accountable for
because if they don't need it they don't
want to have the blame for it which is
pretty despicable when it comes to an
emergency set a timeline set a goal and
get it done and they're not doing
anything i kind of don't blame dod for
the saying well like we just got this
assignment last night i mean they could
have been doing something a long time
ago it doesn't cost 28 million dollars
joey to change the import rules
well there are two domestic uh i i i was
really amazed at the fact that um you
know as people we've been around
anywhere between
how biblical you are maybe 8 000 years
as human beings right and so for 8 000
years we've been making people and
feeding them and now we're so reliant on
a synthetically made formula that if
four companies can't make enough where
do we go so i looked in as is goat's
milk and wet nurses
that i mean you talk about handmaid's
tale that puts us back a couple of
centuries right there but that just
shows you where we are and just how
fragile we are as a society and how
important it is that we worry when the
government does dumb things or or
jeopardizes industries i mean we talk
about we want to be driving electric
cars and we can't even figure out how to
produce fossil fuels anymore
and the idea that baby formula is
today's issue but it's one issue after
another to where the government is so
deeply tied to it or so restrictive in
it i mean we have kale and avocados that
are protected as an agricultural
industry in case we go to war because
california was better at lobbying than
say other places in the country that
might produce something we actually
would want to eat if we had nothing else
to eat and so this is the type of
legislation that gets passed and nobody
ever talks about and and not until
there's a crisis like this do we go back
and go oh
why don't we import
you just came up today foreign new york
right what what on the gas prices on
energy prices and diesel fuel what do
you hear well i know a lot more people
that drive diesels than probably a lot
of you guys right now to get to work you
know what it means it's the difference
between making 500 this week on that job
and breaking even right and that's what
matters that's what hurts people i mean
i drive a diesel that sucks for me but i
don't have to drive a diesel
to get to work a lot of people have to
exactly it's private diesel to get food
on the table or that'll cloud the field
that's exactly right i had guys come
over and and put some grass in the yard
that diesel truck and brought it over
and uh and he said man i'm glad we could
make it here today but i had to wait
till i could schedule enough jobs to
make the trip worthwhile and he's coming
from 10 minutes away right wow the
diesel fuel issue is one keep an eye on
it jim garrity at national review wrote
about it earlier this week and i've been
learning more about it
and talking to people like you raise
goats raise goats raise goats they can
eat literally anything and apparently
their milk is safe for babies that's not
my medical opinion
jessica's gonna go get a gun
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else